this Italian made industrial pasta maker
is designed for restaurants and smaller
pasta suppliers the machine is only five
feet wide but it's still capable of
mixing the dough and pressing it into a
variety of pasta shapes the machine can
turn dough into ravioli or assorted
types of long and short pasta the
machines three stations the extruder the
ravioli maker and the pasta cutter are
constructed from stainless steel parts
a computer-guided punch press makes the
required holes and slots workers insert
pieces into a press to bend them to the
required shape
this is a cover for one of the machine's
components once all the pieces are ready
workers weld them together the machine's
pasta cutter uses stainless steel
cutting rollers to slice the pasta each
roller starts out as a stainless steel
rod a computer-guided mill carves
grooves into it the groove width
determines the width of the pasta the
pasta cutter contains four pairs of
rollers that cut the pasta to different
widths two millimeter wide tile Eenie
four millimeter wide fettuccine eight
millimeter wide talia kelly and twelve
millimeter wide pappardelle rollers are
available in additional sizes workers
install for cars finding pairs of steel
combs underneath the rollers the combs
gently scrape the dough out of the
grooves to eject the cut pasta next
workers install the gears that turn the
rollers the gears engage one another so
that the rollers revolve at the same
speed this ensures that the cutter
operates smoothly and quietly the motor
turns the larger main gear which moves
the others
they mount protective covers this
critical safety feature prevents users
fingers from getting caught in the
rollers at the base of the cutter they
mount a smooth laminating roller this
roller thins the dough sheet before the
cutting rollers slice it they install
the electrically powered motor that
turns the main gear then the handle that
moves the laminating roller here they've
removed the protective covers to
demonstrate how the cutting rollers
operate next they build the extruder
they mount a blade in the dough mixer
and connect it to an electric motor
the extrusion tube is located directly
below the dough mixer the dough is
pushed through a bronze die in the
extrusion to the dyes can be changed to
make different types of pasta one die
makes a flat sheet of dough for cutting
long pasta or making ravioli other dies
can be used to make short pasta such as
fusilli or rotini the machines third
station is the motorized ravioli maker
it also has interchangeable dies to make
different shapes of ravioli now this
machine is ready to make pasta first
they pour in the dough ingredients and
mix for 15 minutes then they pull a
lever to feed the dough through the
extruder this is the die that makes a
dough sheet for the long pasta cutter or
ravioli maker they cut the dough off the
extruder and put it through the cutters
laminating roller to thin it then they
feed it through the rollers in one of
the cutting slots to make ravioli
they extrude to narrow sheets and put
them through the ravioli maker a tube
injects the filling between the sheets
before the die crimps them together a
cooling system built into the extruder
prevents the dough from heating up as
it's forced through the die this keeps
the pasta fresh for a long time